Okay.
That was this one meeting of that the
World Economic Forum,
uh,
conducts out of maybe 20 meetings during
New Year around the world.
But Davos is so called the annual
meetings.
So,
uh,
it is dinorah just of our meetings and
it is the meeting which is attended by
the highest level of the participants
have a CEO's heads of state,
academia,
civil society,
international organizations.
Uh,
and so every component of society is
represented there.
And the purpose is to talk about the
major issues confronting us on a global
basis.
I think the effects have been very,
very positive because the forum promotes
dialogue between various stakeholders
that the form is,
the form is just a platform that brings
together people from all the components
of society.
It sit down around the table and talk
about the issues.
And that's pretty unique because in
today's world it's hard to,
uh,
hard to achieve anything without
gathering all the stakeholders together.
It will achieve first understanding of
the issues or awareness of some of the
issues and the form positions itself as
a catalyst to action.
So we're not ourselves involved directly
into doing something,
but we are,
uh,
we are a catalyst throughout those
dialogue,
those discussions,
those meetings,
things come out of there are being put
in place either directly by some of the
participants or by a group of
participants.
We have meetings in,
in Asia,
we have meeting in Latin America and
Africa and the Middle East in Europe,
in the states.
So,
uh,
and we have annual meetings with major
one being that was the other one being
in China every year.
And really the whole world is
represented as well as all,
cause I said component society from
everywhere.
Yeah.